hey guys it's max I am a huge fan of
Samsung's Galaxy buds I've been using
them ever since they came out about a
year ago but there were a few things
that were kind of downsides limitations
with the original Galaxy buds and with
the new Galaxy buds plus Samsung has
said that they addressed those issues
now we actually made a comparison
between these two we covered every
single little detail in that video so
before you watch this video where we're
gonna actually test out their claims and
put it to the test go ahead and just
wait a second go watch that video I'll
wait for you guys and then you guys can
come back and we'll resume alright guys
now let's jump into it I want to be
skipping over those details focusing on
what they actually fixed and changed and
as you guys could tell I have the galaxy
buzz plus here they have a new case that
is glossy and I have a brand-new pair of
original Galaxy busts to make sure this
test is fear the first thing that I want
to test out is the sound quality so
previously it was pretty good but not
great and with the new galaxy buds plus
they now have dual drivers where a lot
of other earbuds don't have that and
that should improve it now I'm looking
for a better sound quality especially in
the highs and also maybe some better
volume because there's your galaxy buds
are a little bit quiet so let's go ahead
and test that out let's start out with
the original galaxy buds not bad so far
good bass lacking on the volume for sure
and the clarity in the highs just like I
remember it pretty much now the reason
you should sound better and hopefully be
louder as well is because they have dual
drivers instead of one should give it an
advantage very interesting very
interesting
definitely more bass but that's not what
I really wanted I didn't want more bass
the bass was really good I wanted louder
with clear highs okay
flipping back to be honest they actually
sound quite similar but since the note
allows you to do dual audio will send it
to both I'm gonna put one in each ear
and try to listen that way okay alright
well that helped interesting little
agency was kind of off making me think
that the chip in here is better I think
we'll have to test that out now I could
definitely tell the difference so the
basin here sounds much more like an
actual subwoofer if you have a dedicated
unit
it sounds more boomy sounds deeper
richer even that's a little bit too
heavy I think which you can turn down in
the EQ whereas this one sounds more like
a cell phone where you hear something
what does it feel like bass okay this is
getting interesting so I just listened
to a few more songs different genres and
I looked at the EQ and I noticed
something the original Galaxy buds they
have five different EQ settings in the
galaxy wearables app and it's defaulted
to dynamic and in my review I mentioned
that the default sounded the best to me
now the new galaxy buds plus they
actually add another mode called normal
so there's six presets and the default
is no longer dynamic it is set to normal
and when I compare them at the start
they sounded pretty similar not that big
of a difference but when you switch to
the dynamic mode these things come alive
not only do they get louder but they
definitely sound better as well and in
the EDM song and then I listened to a
hip-hop song there are noticeable
differences when you're going back and
forth you can definitely tell but when I
switch to a metal rock song wow these
sound much better you have the nice base
from the lows from that driver you have
a lot more clarity with the drums the
high hats the electric guitars and the
vocals I mean there is a world of a
difference especially in Iraq music we
have all those different sounds and
instruments between them that's if you
switch to the dynamic mode and I was
wondering why in the world do they not
default to that why would they add a
normal mode and Vadim made a great point
what if they had to do that to get the
battery life rating up that's why it's
defaulted to the normal mode because the
battery in these new Galaxy buds plus
they're about 50% larger inside the bud
themselves but their rating for the
battery life is about 85% better battery
life and since in the normal mode
they're not pushing as hard it's quieter
it's not doesn't sound as good that is
going to make a difference in pattern
life so if you're buying some Galaxy
buds plus
go into your settings the first thing
you do in switch it to that that dynamic
mode that's when these things start to
come alive all right guys now time to
compare the latency I did notice a
little bit of a difference when I had
both of them connected but let's go
ahead and I'm gonna put this up here I
don't know if you guys will be able to
hear but I'm a switch you definitely do
notice some delay if you guys can hear
it and now with the galaxy buds plus it
does seem a little bit faster Jess I
ain't like I notice when I had both of
them paired up and then I actually
tested both side by side many times and
we're seeing about a 100 milliseconds to
maybe about 150 milliseconds difference
between its use so that's not a massive
difference but yes latency has improved
now if you're listening music are you
watching youtube video that doesn't
matter because they'll wait for the
video to sync up but if you're in a game
you don't have that convenience and not
so when you notice at the difference now
the last complaint that most people had
was the microphone quality with the
original Galaxy buds where they sounded
very bad like you're underwater pretty
much now Samsung has tried to address
this by adding another microphone to the
Galaxy buds plus so we have an extra one
on the outside now and let's put their
claims to the test and see how these
compare I'm gonna go ahead and pair
these up
I'm gonna call Vadim and we're actually
recording the audio that he's getting
from his phone during a phone call
because that's different than just
recording to a Notes app on your phone
this is a microphone quality test during
a phone call using the original Galaxy
buds
this is a microphone quality test during
a phone call using the new Galaxy buds
plus you guys go ahead and let me know
which one of these sounded better I
doubt the Galaxy buds will sound better
but how much better do the buzz plus
sound does Sampson do a good enough job
of course it's not gonna sound as good
as our $500 shotgun microphone plugged
into a professional recorder but
hopefully it's a good improvement make
sure to comment down below now what are
my thoughts overall especially in the
sound quality well at first I was a bit
disappointed but when we switch to that
dynamic mode it made a hue
difference a world of a difference and
these definitely sound a lot better so
if you have the original galaxy buds and
you're not happy with the sound or even
maybe just the loudness that's coming
out of them there is a massive
improvement with the buzz plus Samsung
did a fantastic job of course the
battery life rating is higher as well
and in that dynamic mode you might not
get all those 11 hours but the battery
is 50% larger so it's definitely gonna
be an improvement and I think that's
very important you say year two years
down the line when your batteries start
you know not lasting as long having the
extra capacity is definitely going to
help now there are some other
differences between these two that I
cover in my full comparison that has
every single detail listed so make sure
to check that out but overall I would
absolutely spend the extra money on the
Galaxy buds plus you know MSRP is only
20 bucks more but on Amazon you can pick
these up for about a hundred bucks right
now and we'll have links down below but
I would gladly pay the extra $50 to have
these new ones now you can't actually
buy these refurbished for about 17 which
we'll also link down below and at that
point it's kind of a tougher choice if
you're really in a budget these are
still a good option but I would say if
you can spring for the extra money that
extra money I'd absolutely go for the
buds plus now if you want to see our
comparison to the air pods and the ear
pods Pro you guys could do that right
over there if you guys want to see more
videos like this one click that
subscribe button and enable
notifications down below this has been
max now see you in the next video
[Music]